the office is leaving Netflix in 2021 no
no fans actually went bananas but here's
the deal NBC Universal bought the rights
to the tune of 500 million dollars a
five-year deal for their upcoming um
streaming service so they've got a good
start yes they do those residuals for
the actors and die hard fans of dunder
mifflin have plenty to say about it
Phyllis yeah well the office is on the
move people even though it was the most
popular show on Netflix even beating
friends you will not die this gif of
Michael says it all with over 1 million
likes no please no no and while fans are
screaming for a reboot the cast isn't I
think people would be disappointed
that's what she said yeah it was kind of
you can't you can't go home again that
way I think the cast is very busy doing
other things I think the show is so
perfect in my mind and I want a reunion
with just the cast that'd be awesome
like at my house that's been happening
actually Jenna hosting this war a quote
I had brunch with these oddballs today
love you Mindy Kaling and on-screen
boyfriend BJ Novak party this week at
Mindy's 40th birthday party jenna
fischer and john was teasing Jenna
during the recent Stanley Cup Finals
they like different teams
and we actually bonded with this crew
during our set business in fact John
often began his takes by singing our
theme I mean we being just about to roll
and I'd be like I'm sorry guys but I did
it so much that the rest of the crew
needed me I feel very blessed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]